so welcome back today we're going to
cover model selection and regularization
but we have a special guest my former
graduate student Daniella Whitton hi
welcome Danielle thank you Daniella is
not University of Washington but maybe
you want to tell students a bit about
yourself and how you got to be here yeah
well I um in college I studied math and
biology and when I was graduating I knew
I knew at a grad school in something but
didn't really decide on one particular
thing that I wanted to study for the
rest of my life and so I ended up doing
a PhD in statistics and I was lucky
enough to do it at Stanford with Rob and
I graduated in 2010 moved up to Seattle
and I'm now an assistant professor at
the University of Washington in the
biostat department there
and uh I didn't invite Danielle here
just because she's she's a great student
and friend but also she's a co-author of
the textbook and this this course is
based so uh Danielle and I are going to
give today's talk together
so we're going to talk about model
selection regularization so let's recall
the
linear model we've talked about already
in the course we have response variable
Y and we're going to model it as a
function of some predictors or features
X1 through XP and we've talked about
least squares for doing that uh earlier
in the course and in in later on the
course we'll talk about ways of making
that model more General making it
non-linear for example or uh we'll we'll
have
um
additive or not but non-linear models in
chapter in the the lectures that cover
chapter seven we'll consider non-linear
models in chapter eight things like
trees and boosting but today actually
we're going to stick to the linear model
and talk about a different way of
fitting the linear model
why well because of the the model
although it's very simple and it's
actually been around since probably the
1920s and 1930s uh is a it's a very
important model because it's it's simple
which means it can be interpreted
there's a small number of coefficients
typically if we have a small number of
features that are important it all it
also it predicts future data quite well
in a lot of cases despite the fact it's
simple so we want to talk today about
ways of of a finger model that improving
on least squares by selecting or
shrinking the the coefficients of
features to make the model more
interpretable and in some cases to
predict better so we'll talk about a
number of methods of doing that today
um
and I'll just say a little more about
these the two objectives
when the number of features is bigger
than the number of samples and we've
talked about that in the core survey
this is a situation that comes up more
and more often these days where we have
a lot of features you measure on
patients or in business maybe on a stock
or
um
um in other situations you can it's
cheap to measure things now and it's
often the case when that P might be much
bigger than the number of samples so in
that situation of course we can't use
fully squares because these the solution
is not even defined so somehow we have
to reduce the number of features and
thus becomes more and more important not
just to obtain a solution but to avoid
feeding the data too hard so when we
um
want to predict better well it will
shrink or regularize or select features
in order to improve the prediction
and along the same lines that we have a
small number of features the model
becomes more interpretable right if we
if we hand our collaborator a few
hundred features and say these are
important that might be hard to
interpret if we compare them down to the
most important five or ten it becomes a
a
it's easier to interpret and from a
scientific point of view more useful so
we call
uh feature selection is is a way of of
choosing among features to find the ones
that are most informative
so we'll talk about three classes of
techniques in today's lecture
subset selection where we try to find
among the P predictors the ones that
that are the most related to the
response and we'll see different flavors
of subset selection
um
best subset selection we'll we'll look
we'll try to look among all possible
combinations of features that found that
find the ones that are the most
predictive and then we will talk about
four and and backward stepwise methods
which don't try to find the best among
all possible combinations but try to do
an intelligent search through the space
of models so fourth step wise backward
stepwise in all subsets and then some
more modern techniques known as
shrinkage methods in which we don't
actually select variables explicitly but
rather we we put on a penalty to
penalize the model for the um the number
of coefficients or the size of
coefficients in various ways so we'll
talk about Ridge regression and the
lasso in the shrinkage section now
finally in the third section
Dimension reduction we'll talk about
ways of finding combinations of
variables
extracting important combinations of
variables and then using those
combinations as as the um the features
in regression we'll talk about PCR
principal components regression and
partial least squares in that
those settings so three different
classes of math three classes of methods
we'll talk about today
the things about today's lecture
context of learning aggression so if
you're trying to predict some
quantitative response and you want to
fit a less flexible but perhaps more
predictive and also more interpretable
model these are ways that you can shrink
in a sense your your usual least Square
solution in order to get better results
but these can just as well these
Concepts can just as well be applied in
the context of logistic regression or
really your favorite model depending on
the data set that you have at hand and
the type of response that you're trying
to predict and so so even though linear
regression is really what we'll be
talking about here these these really
apply to logistic and other types of
models
okay so Danielle is going to first of
all tell us about subset selection
so best subset selection is a really
simple idea and the idea here is suppose
that we
to actually have a simpler model that
involves only a subset of those P
predictors well the natural way to do it
is to consider every possible subset of
p predictors and to to choose the best
model out of all out of every single
model that just contains some of the
predictors
and so the way that we do this is in a
very organized way we first create a
model that we're going to call m0 and m0
is the no mod is the null model that
contains no predictors it just contains
an intercept and we're just going to
predict the sample mean for each
observation
so that's going to give us m0
and now we're gonna we're gonna try to
create a model called M1 and M1 is going
to be the best model that contains
exactly one predictor so in order to get
M1
we need to look at all P models that
contain exactly one predictor and we
have to find the best among those P
models
next we want to find a model called M2
that's going to be the best model that
contains two predictors
so how many models are there that
contain two predictors if we have if we
have p predictors in total and the
answer is p choose 2.
so if you haven't seen this notation
before this is this notation is written
like this it's pronounced choose so this
means P choose two
and it's equal to P factorial
divided by 2 factorial times P minus 2
factorial
and that is actually the number of
possible models that I can get that
contain exactly two predictors out of P
predictors total
and um so I can consider all P choose
two models containing two predictors I'm
going to choose the best one and I'm
going to call it M2 and so on I can keep
on getting the best model with three
predictors four predictors and so on up
to the best model with p predictors
so if I'm choosing the best model out of
all models containing three predictors
in order to get let's say M3 I can do
that in a pretty straightforward way
because I can just say that out of all
models containing three predictors the
best one is the one with the smallest
residual sum of squares or equivalently
the largest r squared
and so in this way I get a best model
containing 0 1 2 all the way through P
predictors I've called them m0 m1m2 all
the way through MP
and now I'm on to step three and in this
final step all that I need to do is
choose the best model out of m0 through
MP
and in order to do this actually
um this this step three is a little bit
subtle because we need to be very
careful that we choose a model that
really has the smallest test error
rather than the model that has the
smallest training error
and so there are a number of techniques
that we can use to choose a single best
model from among m0 to MP
um NDS include prediction error
estimated through cross-validation
um as well as some methods that we're
going to talk about later in this
lecture which you might not have seen
before and these include mallow CP
Bayesian information Criterion and
adjusted r squared
so we'll come back to some of those
topics in a few minutes
so here's an example on the credit data
set and we saw this this data set in one
of the earlier chapters
and this is a data set that contains 10
predictors
involving things like number of credit
cards and credit rating and credit limit
and the goal is to predict a
quantitative response which is credit
card balance
and so what we can do is um we can look
at every single model
that contains a subset of these 10
predictors
and these models are actually plotted
here on the left hand side
so here this x-axis is the number of
predictors it actually goes from 1 to 11
because one of these predictors is
categorical with three levels and so um
we used a couple of Demi variables to
encode that
and on the y-axis is the residual sum of
squares for each of the possible models
so for instance like this dot right here
indicates a model that contains one
predictor with a pretty terrible
residual sum of squares and all the way
down here we've got a model with 11
predictors that has a pretty decent
residual sum of squares so the reason
that there's a lot of dots in this
picture is because there's a lot of
possible sub models given 10 total
predictors
and in fact as we're going to see in a
couple minutes there's 2 to the 10 sub
models so there's actually two to the 10
dots in this picture although some of
them are sort of on top of each other
and so this red line here indicates the
best model of each size so this red this
red dot right here is m0
that's excuse me it's this is M1 what I
just what I just showed you is M1 so
that's the best model containing one
predictor because that is the smallest
residual sum of squares this is the best
model containing two predictors this is
M3 best model containing three
predictors and so on so when we perform
best subset selection what we really do
is we Trace out this curve to when we
get m0 through MP
and now we're just going to need to find
a way to choose you know is M10 better
than or worse than M4 and so on we're
just going to have to choose among that
lower Frontier
so so on the left hand side here we see
a number of predictors against residual
sum of squares
and on the right hand side we've got
number of predictors against r squared
and as we saw in chapter 3 r squared
just tells you the proportion of
variance explained by a linear
regression model by a least squares
model and so once again we see a whole
lot of gray dots indicating every
possible
model containing a subset of these 10
predictors and then the the the red line
shows the best model of each size so
again this is the M1 that we saw earlier
this is M2
over here is M10
and um what we notice is that as the
models get bigger as we look at larger
and larger models the residual sum of
squares decreases
and the r squared increases so
um do we have any idea of why that's
happening
maybe Rob can tell us
I can tell you yeah so it's because as
you add in variable things cannot get
worse right if you have a subset of size
three for example and you look for the
best subset of size four
at the very worst you could set the
coefficient for the fourth variable to
be zero and you do the same as you'll
have the same uh error as for the three
variable model so the curve can never it
can never get worse it can be flat if
you clear the slide here we can see it
looks like it's actually flat from about
three predictors onto
from three above up to 11. but it's
certainly it's not going to go up but it
can it can it cannot it can go be flat
as it is in this case but we can't do
any worse by adding a predictor and
actually what Rob just said relates to
the idea that um you know remember on
the on the previous slide here in step
three when we were talking about best
subset selection we had this step and I
said that in order to choose among the
best model of each size we're going to
need to be really careful we're going to
have to use cross validation or CP Bic
adjusted r squared and that really
relates to what's going on here because
you know if if I ask to you hey what's
the best model with eight predictors
you'd say okay here are all of the model
with models with a predictors and like
clearly this is the best one it's got
the smallest residual sum of squares
there's no argument
but if I ask you which is better this
model here
or this model there
Suddenly It's Not So straightforward
because you're kind of comparing apples
and oranges you're comparing a model
with four predictors to a model with
eight predictors you can't just look at
which one has a smaller residual sum of
squares because you would because of
course the one with eight predictors is
going to have a smaller residual sum of
squares so in order to really in a
meaningful way choose among a set of
models with different predictors we're
going to have to be careful and we'll
talk about that in a few minutes good